-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)
What a Merry Christmas special
it's been.
And now it's time for the last
Christmas gift of the evening.
I'm going to give Bebe
her exclusive.
Oh! Finally!
-Here it is.
-Okay. (clears throat)
(whispering):
I... came up...
with Christmas.
What? No, that's
the title of your special.
And you didn't come up
with Christmas.
I came up with my Christmas.
And it's totally different
from regular Christmas.
Regular Christmas is supposed
to be about celebrating
the birth of Jesus--
a man who was selfless and kind
and died for our sins.
But I'm greedy and petty.
And you die for my sins!
I'm the opposite of Christ.
I'm the Antichrist.
But I am a savior
of myself, my family,
and some of the worst,
most hateful ideas
that decent Americans thought
were long dead.
Stop waiting
for a Christmas miracle.
Whatcha see is whatcha get.
I'm not gonna suddenly turn
into a Christian...
or a populist...
or a good friend...
or a good father...
or become presidential...
or even a politician who
actually believes what he says.
(sneezes, sniffs)
I'm me.
Get used to it.
Wise up.
(piano playing mellow intro)
(snoring nearby)
♪ It's not ♪
♪ What you thought ♪
♪ When you first ♪
♪ Began it ♪
♪ You got ♪
♪ What you want ♪
♪ You can hardly ♪
♪ Stand it ♪
♪ Though by now you know ♪
♪ It's not ♪
♪ Going to stop ♪
♪ Till you wise up ♪
♪ You're sure ♪
♪ There's a cure ♪
♪ And you have finally ♪
♪ Found it ♪
♪ You think ♪
♪ One drink ♪
♪ Will shrink you till ♪
♪ You're underground ♪
♪ And living down ♪
♪ But it's ♪
♪ Not going to stop ♪
♪ It's not ♪
♪ Going to stop ♪
♪ Till you wise up ♪
♪ Prepare a list ♪
♪ For what you need ♪
♪ Before you sign away ♪
♪ The deed ♪
♪ It's not going ♪
♪ To stop ♪
♪ It's not ♪
♪ Going to stop ♪
♪ Until you ♪
(coughing):
♪ Wise up ♪
♪ No, it's not going ♪
♪ To stop ♪
♪ Till you wise up ♪
♪ No, it's not going ♪
♪ To stop ♪
♪ So just give up. ♪
♪ ♪
-(song ends)
-(cheering, applause)
Unless... unless...
Americans got more creative
with their civil disobedience
and used the Constitution as
a weapon against the main person
who's sworn to uphold it.
And can you imagine
if the Democratic Party
actually rallied behind
a coherent message that speaks
to the working class people
I conned?
They could even take
my catchphrase:
Make America great again.
It's the perfect slogan for
whoever runs against me in 2020,
because I'm making America
a lot of things,
but great isn't one of them.
-(gunshot, glass shatters)
-Whoa! -Aah!
Oh! I think I shot
the coal vent, Dad!
Oh. Wait a minute.
Is that what I think it is?
It's coaling, everyone!
-(chuckling)
-It's coaling!
It's a Coal-Mas miracle!
Coal-ball fight!
(happy shouts, laughter)
♪ We wish you
a Merry Christmas ♪
-♪ We wish you
a Merry Christmas ♪ -Bye-bye!
-(cheering, applause)
-♪ And a Happy New Year!